Ask voters what worries them and you’ll
find jobs rank near the top of most polls.
Politicians often blame trade agreements,
regulations, immigration, or workers in other countries for taking jobs.
They tend to ignore another disruptive force
to the U.S. worker: automation.
Automation has been displacing humans for
decades.
Assembly line workers, switchboard operators,
gas station attendants are just some of those
whose jobs have disappeared.
More recently, jobs in service and retail
have taken a major hit.
Just think, when was the last time you used
a travel agent to book a trip?
Or you went to the mall for something you could
buy on your phone?
For many other types of jobs, the future doesn’t
look much better.
Millions of truck drivers, office employees
and fast food workers could be displaced.
But automation is not a zero sum game.
As it eliminates jobs it creates others.
The World Economic Forum estimates 75 million jobs could disappear over the next 4 years.
But it also expects automation to create over 130 million new positions.
That’s a net gain of nearly 60 million jobs worldwide.
The challenge is these new jobs require different
skills.
Manual labor will matter less.
Computer programming and coding will matter
more.
Millions of American workers don’t yet have the training to make this transition to a more automated world.
That’s one reason policymakers are discussing
things like tuition-free colleges and money
for life-time learning programs.
They are pushing for high-speed internet
for every corner of the country.
And they are demanding greater protections
for workers in the gig economy.
America’s history is a story of technological
change and adaptation.
One-hundred years ago, the invention of the assembly line and mass production forced American workers to learn new skills.
To help them, the U.S. government expanded
education.
Businesses provided job-training.
And workers organized in unions to demand
higher wages and fair treatment.
With automation, Americans and America will again need to adapt.
The future of work depends on it.